we just heard from your colleague
bernard jenkin he says that dino harding
should effectively be sacked as the head
of test and trace do you agree
no i'm afraid i don't agree i think that
what dido has done is put together and
drive forward a team that has
come on so much in the last few months
we've got a scheme that's going from
having
no tests and traits obviously before the
virus to building up a scheme now
that means we've tested over over 28
million people it's more than anywhere
else in europe
1.1 million people now who have been
contacted through the scheme
we want to see it improve want to see it
grow and get better and better that's
how we fight this virus
but actually i think dido and the team
have done a very good job to get to
where we are
very good job we spent 12 billion pounds
so far on test and trace that's more
than you spend on nurseries and
universities
in a year and yet sage the scientific
advisors say it's having a marginal
impact on transmission
the chief scientific advisor says it's
very clear there's room for improvement
i mean it's not exactly a success is it
well look we agree and the prime
minister of cell said this week want to
see it improve as i just said myself
we want to see this develop and grow but
i also just would say sophie
be really careful around some of the
figures the 12 billion figure you just
quoted
is actually for the whole tested scheme
it's not just that tracking part of test
and trace it's
it's a bit misleading to suggest it's
just that it's much wider and as i say
that is a skill it's in the name but
it's now tested more here than anywhere
else in europe
um it's test and trace the clues in the
name testing and tracing
um a submittee of sage said in april
that a successful
contact is wrong would require around 80
of contacts to be traced and isolated
rapidly i.e within two days
so that's what the level that it needs
to be working uh
effectively successfully when was the
last time test and trace reached 80
of people's contacts well as the prime
minister said this week we want to see
it improve i would just say so if you
look
you're quite right that cost is around
tests and trades but it's wrong to
suggest it's
the cost of contact trading it's not
it's a whole program of work
as i say is one of the biggest if not
the biggest now in europe we do want to
see it improve that's why we're putting
more support in to ensure we've got more
robotics more people more laboratory
capacity to see it get to the state
level we want it to be
ultimately we will beat this virus but
all of us with our self-responsibility
particularly if we've tested positive
making sure that we isolate in the way
that the guidance outlines
so the question i asked was when was the
last time that test and trace reached
80 of contacts it didn't reach 80 of
contact since
the 17th of june it's been falling since
then
it hit a new low of just 59 of contacts
in the most recent weeks i mean on
sage's own definition
that is not a successful test and trace
system is it
well as i say as the prime minister said
we want to see it improve of course we
are testing
more and more people some 360 000 test
capacity 340 000
tests completed on the last days figures
getting to half a million by the end of
this month so that's been growing
exponentially we want to see the other
part of the system
catching up so it can get back to doing
that 80
that's why we want to see that system
improve as we've outlined ourselves just
this week
i understand why the government's keen
to emphasize the number of tests that
we're carrying out and as you say you
know compared to lots of european
countries we are carrying out an awful
lot of tests
but that only matters if people get the
results back
in a timely way and actually if you look
at the later statistics
the most recent week just 15 percent of
in-person tests were received
within 24 hours i mean it's no point
testing all these people
if they're then just wandering around
for 48 hours spreading the virus
well actually i disagree with you though
i think first of all it is important
that we test people that's why i think
it's right that we are clear about the
fact we're testing more than anywhere
else in europe
when people get the result of their
tests whether it's within a day or less
or
occasionally sadly taking that 48 hours
that's when people need to once they're
clear they've got symptoms people should
be isolating
anyway if somebody's had a test and then
proves positive
they should be isolating following the
guidance that's what we've all got to do
in terms of our own
self-responsibility so increasing the
testing is hugely important what we also
want to see
as i say as we've outlined this week is
an improvement in the other part of the
system
seeing that contact work increase the
speed of the testing results come
through
more quickly and that's why we're
looking to increase the capacity on that
side with more laboratory capacity as
well
my colleague conway recently revealed
that the government is paying
multi-million
million wages to for people to work on
the test and trade system so executives
from
boston consulting group paid day rates
of about seven thousand pounds that's
equivalent to an annual salary of 1.5
million and this is a system that in
your own words some
improvement you'd like to see
improvement is that really value for
money
well we've had to work quite i think
it's quite right but the government's
been working across the public sector
and with the private sector as well
trying to bring
the very best expertise to a virus as
you said
at the beginning sophie is a new virus
this is unprecedented we're all
learning more and more as we go forward
we're looking to improve and develop
the way we respond to that virus as we
move forward that's why things have been
able to change
in a positive way as well since we first
were dealing with this and had that full
lockdown back in february march earlier
this year i think it is right that we
work across the private sector
in partnership with the public sector to
see the inroads we're seeing and the
workers
you touched on a few moments ago with
bernard around the vaccine as well
that's coming
through because of that partnership
between the public and the private
sector
i just want to uh ask you about some
reports that in the newspapers there
today reports that the government is
looking
at cutting the 14-day isolation period
if someone in your household
has got covered or if you're traveling
from abroad
to ten days potentially even seven days
is that true
well we're looking at the moment the
teams are looking at what we can do
around those isolation periods this will
be scientifically led
as i say we're learning more about the
virus every single day it's
still a relatively new virus in terms of
disease and as we learn and the
scientists are able to gauge us we can
look at whether we're able to reassess
that we're not ready to make a
final decision or announcement on that
yet but we want to make sure we're
moving with the science
and indeed again allowing people to live
and work within this virus
as best as we can whilst always making
sure we protect people's health
and the nhs is it not just about the
science though
is it also about the fact that you're
worried people are just not following
the rules
no this is going to be scientifically
leo we've always said we want to make
sure we get the balance right we want to
protect lives
protect our nhs ensure that it can
continue to deal with the issues that he
has
through the winter but also making sure
that our economy can continue to develop
and grow and that people can
as far as we possibly can within the
constraints of the
safety we have to follow with this virus
live as close to a normal life as we can
as we get forward to a point where we
can go back
to living a normal life that does mean
that while we've got this virus and as
we are
putting those guidance points in place
that we will follow the guidance the
best of our ability to ensure
that we're keeping not just ourselves
but our communities
safe from the virus where we can so
is it also right that uh company bosses
city bankers
might actually be exempt from the same
rules that everyone else has to follow
to try and promote global britain as
reported by the sunday times is that
really
true no no it's not i have to say any
changes that are made will apply
to everybody obviously there are things
we've done through the virus like
getting testing out to frontline nhs
workers first it's properly led
again by scientific and medical need but
when we look at things like that if
there's any changes of that type it will
apply to everybody
okay now we've got to talk about free
school meals
i have to say it feels like you've drawn
the short straw this morning you're the
minister who has been wheeled out to
defend
the government's policy and explain why
it is that you don't want to
fund meals for poor children over the
holidays
have you done something wrong in a past
life
well i always see it as a positive if i
get to spend the first part of my sunday
chatting with you sophie as i did a few
weeks ago i think actually
our our policy on this is i know this is
a very emotive issue it's a sensitive
issue and it suddenly affects families
in my constituency
as well as around the country i think
the position we have taken is the right
position because what we're looking to
do
is ensure we deal with child poverty at
the core and put the
structure in place that means even in
school holidays children can get access
to the food that they need
enjoy the flattery in the answer but
sadly it's not going to make me move off
the topic
that quickly um i'm genuinely trying to
work out why
the government is opposing this is it
because it's too expensive or because
is it because you don't agree with the
principle of it
well actually sophia i would say the
premise of your question is is not
entirely right
first of all we support three school
meals they've been in place since 1906.
i've had them i'm asking you about we're
in a different place today
well well obviously by definition
schools are not open in the holidays so
we're in a different place to where we
were earlier in the summer where we had
the full lot down that schools were
closed
99 are now open and they're going into
that period of school holiday the
schools are closed so it's what do we
have in place when schools are closed
we've already
put that facility in place we've
increased universal credit so people got
more support over a thousand pound on
average across the country
for the year but we've also put in place
around 63 million pounds to support
local authorities
to help people in their communities at a
time of hardship very specifically
to allow local authorities they know
their areas best they're closest to the
residents
that they serve and they can put a place
of schemes that they feel can make sure
that people who need that extra support
very targeted and very directly can get
that support we're seeing councils
around the country doing that
for this week very directly the
campaign's been driven by
marcus rashford the manchester united
footballer and it does really feel that
he's touched a nerve
bernie jenkins even saying that the
government's misjudged the mood of the
country on this
sky news understands boris johnson
didn't reply to a personal letter sent
by the footballer in september
shouldn't the prime minister at least
meet with marcus rashford and his task
force now
well i've got to say i think marcus
rashford has run a campaign that's
clearly inspired people
across the country a huge credit to him
for that it's a phenomenal thing to
raise the profile
in the way that he has about child
poverty and he has got such a clear
passion and understanding of that
situation i congratulate him for that
and
actually all those organizations out
there that are running into the cause to
work and help and support people
in their communities as i say our
position as a government is
we support that we're doing that
ourselves and we're putting that money
in place for local authorities
to have to support those most in need
and the welfare system
through the universal credit system as
well is putting that extra supported so
people
can ensure that they can feed their
families properly and healthily
through the school holidays and
obviously when schools are in place free
school meals are there
do you get a sense that you'd be wheeled
out to defend this policy
only for an inevitable u-turn to come
so so the road noise i missed the second
part of that question
do you get the sense that you've been
wheeled out to defend this policy only
for the government to inevitably you
turn on it
actually i think that the idea for the
government is to make sure we've got
a holistic structure in place to make
sure we are supporting those families
and those children
most in need at all times that's what
leveling up in our manifesto is all
about to ensure that we can improve
educational opportunities improve job
opportunities
hugely important obviously post covered
in the future as well and the structure
we've put in place with the welfare
system
as i say through local authorities
through the universal credit system
means that that money and that support
is there
for people who are mostly needing the
school holidays we fully support free
school bills and have
continued to deliver them and will
continue to do so and in the holidays
that's what the welfare system is there
for to ensure
the people who need that help can get it
and i think we've done that in a very
targeted way that means that people who
need their support
can access it in their local areas okay
okay let's move on and brexit talks are
still
uh going on uh how would you rate the
chances of a deal
well i'm hopeful we will get a deal i
think we'll be ready as a country for
whatever happens i think whether we get
a canada style or the australian style
deal we've been doing a huge amount of
work and businesses as well
to be ready for january i think we will
be and there's big opportunities for us
as a country as we go forward but
the teams are now back in that intensive
negotiation and hopefully
there will be a positive outcome with a
deal that means we trade on canada's
style deal but
australia will work for us as well
australia is no deal
let's let's say what it is it's not an
australian deal is it it's no deal
well we already have a deal don't forget
we've left the european union we're in a
transition process still does australia
have with the eu
withdrawal agreement we've got a
protocol that means there is a structure
there already of a deal that means
it's not no deal that's just not correct
sophie i'm afraid but look we want to
get a deal we want to get a deal that
means
we can continue to trade with a free
trade agreement with our friends and
partners in the eu but we've got to do
so in a way that
is yes it's got to be good for our
partners who trade with us but obviously
as the uk government we've got to make
sure that's a deal that's right and
appropriate
for a sovereign country here in the uk
see it's amazing really isn't it you
know the government made a big deal of
calling off the talk saint was all over
and now the talks are magically back on
you're saying you're hopeful
that you're going to get a deal i mean
you must be really flabbergasted by this
surprising turn of events
no i think these are negotiations we
were very clear we're only going to do a
deal if it's a deal that's right
and good and positive for the uk we want
to have one that works with our trading
partners around the world and obviously
in the eu and it's good that michelle
barnier has come back to the table and
is
saying that they are prepared to have a
look at what they could do because the
eu does need to move
be very clear we'll only do a deal if
it's right for the united kingdom
okay um just finally i've done a film
this week we're going to watch it a bit
later in the program it's about
the way that maternity services have
been impacted
during the covert 19 pandemic spoke to
one woman who
gave birth just two weeks ago without
her husband there
and many women also not able to take
their partners to important scan
appointments as well
and one hospital in liverpool at now
tightening up restrictions
as cases rise and how is it acceptable
for women to have to labor go to
important scan appointments
without any support there well i know
how difficult these situations can be
obviously i've got children been through
this experience
myself i was fortunate enough that
obviously i was pre-covered so in the
more normal times kind of also people
want that kind of support rather than we
want people
to have that support around them but
obviously we've got to look at what is
safe for the families and for the nhs
workers
as we're dealing with this virus as well
and it's getting the balance of that
right in a way that means
that we can move forward and that
families can have a safe birth and that
our nhs workers are safe as well